parmi ces nouveaux départements classés
en zone rouge on retrouve la quasi
totalité de la côte d'azur la corse la
martinique la réunion mais aussi la
seine et marne et ses nouveaux
départements s'inscrivent avec d'autres
déjà placé en zone rouge depuis quelques
jours voire quelques semaines comme la
ville de paris la gironde où les alpes
maritimes
alors concrètement les voyages non
essentiels et voyages touristiques
pardon dans ces départements ils sont
tout simplement interdits et les belges
qui serait déjà doivent rentrer dans les
48 heures s'ils ne veulent pas devoir
passer un test et être mis en
quarantaine pendant 14 jours
alors bien sûr les belges pourront se
rendre dans ces zones et départements
classés en zone rouge
à condition qu'ils aient une raisons
professionnelles ou un impératif
familiale
attention les autorités ont prévenu
qu'en cas de manquement à ces
justificatifs
il était envisageable qu'il pose des pv
dans les aéroports et dans les gares ou
tout simplement lors de contrôles
policiers